hi there steve coffin here
you know one subject that comes up all
the time is you know if i learn these
languages what can i do with it you know
the relationship between languages and
work or career profession and so forth
um
okay i want to talk a bit about that
with reference to my own personal
experience
first of all a general statement i
am not aware of a lot of professions
where
you can say hire me because i speak a
lot of languages there are some
obviously if you're an interpreter a
translator a teacher of languages
then those things you know speaking i
speak a lot of languages might get to a
job in most cases what i found with
speaking languages was
that it increased
the opportunities that are going to come
your way
but you still had to have other things
working for you had to have other skills
uh knowledge of a specific you know
sector market an ability to do business
ability to be a
reliable energetic uh person in in any
number of fields
uh but in my own case for example
there's no question that
the fact that i left montreal as an
anglophone
went to france studied there for three
years and the last two was at lancaster
they did politique in paris syanspo and
then i wrote my
canadian diplomatic or foreign service
exam
in french as an anglophone
i am sure that that helped me
uh be selected into the canadian
diplomatic service because they want
people who are at least fluent
so here's a language we're lying here's
a profession where languages count they
want people who are fluent at the very
least in the two official languages so
if an anglophone wrote the
foreign service exam in french that
probably put me in a select group so i
had a better chance of being selected
that was the first thing
when i was in ottawa in my year in
training with the trade commissioner
service
and i heard that the government was
preparing to send someone to learn
chinese i started taking chinese lessons
on my own so that i could go to the
director of personnel and say i hear you
want to send someone to learn chinese
because canada is about to recognize the
people's republic of china i've already
started i just want you to know that so
the fact that that i have already
undertaken you know to start learning
chinese
makes them probably think why wouldn't
we choose him he's already motivated
so that helped
obviously learning chinese then i was
able to go into china help canadian
business people who were negotiating
with their chinese counterparts in
different situations at the canton trade
fair and so forth
i subsequently went to japan lived there
learned japanese
and because i
learned japanese quite quickly on my own
i should add
and i had a lot of contacts in the
forest product sector while working at
the embassy a canadian company that
wanted to set up their own office in
japan
they saw someone me although quite young
at the time who had contacts in the
industry and who spoke japanese so i was
given the job of setting up their
uh representative
or subsidiary in tokyo so
obviously my knowledge of japanese not
only enabled me to
communicate at various levels in the
japanese
lumber
trade sector and not just those
trading company people who spoke english
but a wide variety of people so i got
that job
i subsequently went back to japan for
another company
uh again because i spoke japanese and
had contacts
um
then uh
let's see i guess the next
major sort of language learning spurt
for me was 1987 i was between jobs
i had been hired by a company
that did business in europe and i said
i'm going to really learn up german so i
spent a month
scouring the second-hand bookstores in
vancouver finding books that had
text and and uh vocabulary lists
for each chapter because
in those days i mean i just didn't want
to look every word up in the dictionary
there were no online dictionaries there
was no link so i found a whole pile of
books
excellent books in german
and i found some good uh audio cassettes
for learning german so i did a lot of
listening and reading and learned of
german well it turned out that in the
1990s i did a fair amount of business in
germany and we were selling wood from
canada into germany and so i had
visitors from germany and i traveled in
germany and once you got past the the
main sort of
lumber agents a lot of the
consumers the wood processors the
different uh
customers for our products
were much more comfortable speaking
german than speaking english i think it
helped me do business there
thereafter
we started doing business in sweden
which became a big supplying country for
us
and so i again got after swedish which i
had some background in because i was
born there lived there for five years
forgot swedish but then
uh you know i spent a summer there as a
16 year old
but i decided i'm going to really learn
this language so i got all these audio
books and books and i've mentioned him
on lindquist you know swedish history
and stuff and i ended up doing a fair
amount of business and i think i had
better relations and
developed a better relationship of trust
with my suppliers because i spoke
swedish and when we had meetings and
they wanted me to explain the japanese
market to them in front of their
production people not all of whom were
so fluent in english even in sweden the
fact that i was able to do this and
field questions in swedish and explain
what the customer's requirements were
and the market and how it was structured
all of this in swedish definitely helped
um
those are the main areas where my
languages have helped me i mean
when i set up my own company we did some
business in spain
and i was able to contact people by the
phone and we had some spanish customers
come through and
being able to speak spanish certainly
helped we have a very good customer in
france with whom i speak french all the
time exclusively
um you know my business once i set it up
was primarily marketing to japan so that
i guess the biggest payback was my my
japanese
japanese
language skills which helped me develop
a market position in japan
you know i i think
in business you have to be lucky and you
have to seize opportunities that come
your way the more languages you speak
the more opportunities you're going to
have
but you still have to be
committed sincere hard-working
you have sometimes take chances you
don't want to take ridiculous chances
so you have to have all those other
things
and luck of course to be successful
about the languages just increase
the number of opportunities that are
going to come your way
it increases your opportunity to connect
with people you can connect with more
people you can understand people better
so all of those things are the benefits
of learning to speak a number of
languages and you never know which
languages are going to come in handy
when so i hope that's of
some interest to those of you who
frequently ask you know what are the
benefits of learning other languages
bye for now
you